hello friends I'm with my channel where
we are just about to watch the lost of
uh spot to stay to play I've not seen
any of the week's thankfully I'm very
excited to get into this fresh what
judge jump them right in here so let's
do it
I I don't know what to expect from this
one but I am sort of hoping that maybe
at the end we get an announcement of
when their next conference is I don't
know if they're gonna do that but I
would really like to know if we're
getting that sort of III thing that's
predicted for June third I guess we'll
see great I love the sound of all of
that the stream already looks a lot
better quality than the ghost of
Tsushima one so I wish things were
different
[Music]
I have goosebumps
I love that relationship scotch
please dub definitely excited to see
more about who Elliot is now I guess
I'm leaving tomorrow it's beautiful
do this smart we believe in Jackson
vulnerable
don't they just get to get away with
this how'd you find us you can't stop
this
it definitely looks brill glory all that
stuff which I'm on board with I'm
obviously the treeless for the jump gave
us an indication of that but I really
hope you make it
so just keep being surprised by it I
guess
she really does look different I have to
finish it
there's a cost I hope that we haven't
completely lost the light white-hot in
wonder side of Elly
[Music]
we could have killed you
maybe you should have a good time peace
but I I did hear it on PSX Thea they
announced it I'm vice president of
nayavada and the director of the Last of
Us part two we're just a few weeks away
from launch on June 19th when the game
will finally be in your hands the wait
has been long and we're extremely
grateful for your patience especially
now in the midst of these unprecedented
and challenging times we hope you're all
taking care of yourselves
and that you your friends and your loved
ones are doing ready vibes because of
these extraordinary circumstances we
can't be together in this final stretch
and share the experience like we usually
would so today we're trying something
different something we've never done
before okay
over the next 20 minutes or so we're
going to give you an in-depth look into
what awaits you in the Last of Us part
two I assumed including new details
about the gameplay experience and story
and to cap it all off we'll be showing
him never-before-seen lengthy gameplay
sequence you'll definitely want to stick
around for this sign me up
I was gonna say sorry I cut you off now
that I heard that this is a game about
hate first game was about love what
happened this is about hate I'm supposed
to take her to the fireflies and walk
away I'm worried about that hey were
actually gonna make a cure no you only
catch
you would kill her
the Last of Us part two picks up Ellie
and Joel story several years after the
events of the first game mm-hmm Ellie
and Joel have settled in Jackson Wyoming
amongst a thriving community of
survivors with the threats of the world
kept outside the town's walls
Jackson has been able to find the ghost
of peace and stability Congrats Ellie is
now 19 lives on her own and has been
able to forge lasting relationships
within the community scale of one to ten
how would you rate our kiss from last
night however this piece
Jackson and Ellie suffer a violent and
traumatizing event she dies in early
sets off back into the treacherous
outside a skies in search of retribution
and justice you gotta start it the same
way the first new parts of the country
not previously unexplored in the last
Jill's daughter the story spans multiple
seasons and climates from the
snow-capped mountains of Jackson to the
Loess Pacific Northwest
each introduces a wide range of exterior
and interior environments for you to
navigate and explore rendered in
meticulous detail an unprecedented scale
with the laser narration of the Naughty
Dog Engine our goal was to make these
environments not only beautiful but feel
as grounded and authentic to the cities
they're based on as possible much of the
story unfolds and what remains of
Seattle its locales are incredibly
diverse spanning a dense city center
with a skyline of towering high-rises to
the beautiful suburbs and stormy water
fronts that surround it
the city exhibits drastic shifts in
architecture and with part two women
what personal mechanics that afford
greater exploration and ways to navigate
threats Ellie is not only able to climb
and jump over gaps but she can use ropes
to scale vertical terrain or swings over
obstacles allowing you to discover new
areas resources inside narratives that's
cool for birds to create new strategic
considerations in combat whether it's to
get the jump on enemies or bypass them
entirely
the loss of us part two features some of
the largest environments we've ever
created horseback riding will allow Elly
to quickly cover some of these expansive
terrains
well looks really good too so flooded
that a boat is required to navigate them
however the world of the last of us is
as lush and inviting as it is deadly as
Ellie uncovers the path to finding those
who have wronged her she must face the
many threats of this unknown city well
if we can actually pandemic in the fall
of the quarantine zone Seattle has
become a war zone where two warring
factions find themselves in an ongoing
conflict for territory and resources one
of these groups is the Washington
Liberation Front otherwise known as the
W LF the W are left for a militia group
that began and eventually wrestled
control the city from them they are
highly trained organized and well
equipped with weapons they stole from
the army they occupy much of the city
imprisoning or killing trespassing
gosh-dang
I mean it suits the Pacific Northwest
but damage from a bloody conflict is a
group of religious zealots called casera
fights or scars defined by the self
inflicted deep cuts that they bear
across their faces like the W are left
are deeply tribalistic and territorial
no matter being stealthy using
overgrowth as cover and they use more
silent weapons like bows and arrows clip
her wings
but beyond I guess making survivors so a
threat that originally brought the world
to its knees is very much present every
human is in danger of falling victim to
the infected recently runners who are
more numerous and aggressive in this
game the blind but extremely deadly
clickers and the stalker who sneak and
hide until they're ready to attack with
extreme agility and brutal volume still
anxious last of us part two introduces
new stages of infected such as the
shamblers large heavily armored enemies
that are covered in pustules
upon getting close to you they expel a
furrow Civ spore cloud the burn victims
but our most terrifying and lethal new
forms of infected will have to wait
until you play the game for yourselves I
worry that this game is going to be like
devastating threats to the racial
serious dock every hallway through and
that I can't hide away right now all
these unique skills which is not on the
game an environment does very mature way
of storytelling which you know I
appreciate in a nobler patrol the
streets of Seattle with guard dogs which
are capable of detecting and following
you even while uncover oh wow that's
cool they can pick up your scent and
alert their handlers to your presence
huh very cool
listen mode will reveal your central
keep moving and cause distractions to
avoid detection
stop 25 years after the pandemic began
the world has completely overgrown
rabbit all grass to hide from enemies
and go prone to stay out of sight
however this form of analogue stealth
means you're never fully hidden if
enemies get close enough they can
discover you even ingress when Ellie is
overwhelmed
running away is a viable option you can
also break glass or crawl through tight
spaces to find new paths
very impressive a sized environment a
colonies and any combat situation you
can flee an encounter and reestablished
options to combat but illicit if you
absolutely have to fight your way out
there are a variety of tools at your
disposal Ellie's more agile than most of
her enemies of Sprint and quickly dodge
incoming attacks learning how opponents
attack with different weapons and
mastering the timing of your dodges will
prevent you from taking damage and
create opportunities to counter-attack
you can use throw ball items or
well-placed shots to stun enemies before
dealing oh it's so good or using them as
a shield to protect yourself or buy some
time to figure out your next move
Elly is always alone on her journey
allies will take part in helping you
navigate the environments spot enemies
and meaningfully help you in combat
encounters
the camera angles there will be times
where multiple threats are present
creating new strategic considerations
and opportunities you can choose what a
Bradley's opponent li appropriate
directly or find ways to pit them
against each other
cool I'm glad watching pleased a fight
Capel wait until their numbers have
thinned out and engaged with whoever's
left
who's that is that the guy that was dead
our goal is to create unparallel
attention
coupled with deep systems that give you
greater control and influence over your
journey cool as you play you'll be able
to invest in the broad collection of
crafting items weapon and player
upgrades through training manual
scattered throughout the environment and
scavenging for ingredients these skills
and upgrade manuals cater to a variety
of play styles you may create your own
distinct we also wanted to extend that
agency and personalization to weapons
through our new workbench systems
scavenger parts to modify and improve
your weapons performance and attributes
visualize and become part of your cutter
Grady nonsense yeah cool cool
I already know this game it's gonna make
me so nervous are using the parts and
ingredients that you'll find an
environment which can be crafted into a
wide range of defensive and offensive
items like proximity mines explosive
arrows pistol suppressors and more
feeling because of the way the first
game played on I just care about Ellie
so much I don't want anything to happen
to it and now I'm responsible for the
whole time left behind story like that
[Music]
nice
all of these gameplay systems are meant
to immerse you in the world and make you
feel and lockstep with Ellie's emotional
journey cool as we've said before this
is Naiya dog's largest the most
ambitious game it may seem like we
covered a lot but we've only scratched
the surface of what it's like to play
The Last of Us part two we can't wait
for you to experience it all for
yourself on June 19th thanks Neal I
appreciate that thank you about us to
your left
here's an extended sequence of
never-before-seen gameplay
brilliant enjoy I'll make myself smaller
from this part for you guys just in case
you haven't seen it elsewhere okay
also I really hope you guys call him the
beeping in the backroom
look I know I can get really repetitive
when watching extended things like this
but this is stunning also she's swimming
is the greatest game player available
time she learned to swim I'm proud of
you go I'm proud of you you got it
together ah even underwater bless you
she's swimming sold man I really feel
like this game is a lot of like I would
really want to say about it can't leave
it sits in the same way that they did
with um lost legacy I feel like it's
going to have like a series of mini
sandbox it's connected together like
just very large environments with a lot
of options I feel like naughty dog is
heading in a direction of making things
well that's so linear because I
narratives is so important just less
linear in the actual gameplay structure
which I really like I really liked the
the huge map they had in
don't make a [ __ ] cent hands up
girl named Laura yeah they're clearing
out she's somewhere in there oh really
strong Jesus eyes oh my god Oh
yup she's not an [ __ ] is that or was
that a PSP
oh my god that's the hall I Miami meet
music
she was playing Hall in Miami that's a
Vita and loved that I recognize that
song no way that's so cool
I don't know why that made me so happy a
hotline Miami camera you certain but I
don't know I think that's though
I love in this tall grass catch lots of
pokeyman do some Assassin's Creed okay
love that I hope we can actually play it
like a stealth game it lends itself to
that but I feel like it's so easy to
fail in um control it for for example
one stealth so I hope this is a little
more doable the dogs are gonna make it
hard
also I hate killing don't rhymes I love
that they react when you go oh I only
figured it out oh my cheat day oh no
it's just big piece of wood love a big
piece of wood sorry
dog can't climb building jet fuel can't
melt steel beam don't hurt the dogs time
with that seriously this environments
needs massive solid map
I love a good buy I'm gonna I'm gonna
use that a lot this gameplay looks great
like the variety of stealth kills we've
seen here or techniques that we've seen
here is is impressive do they explain
why Ellie can look through walls some
sort of super here and we've got on a
hand T C I like that a lot it's you know
maybe if that were a second olya that
wouldn't have happened but it didn't
automatically trigger a state of attack
like there it seemed to be different
layers and levels to how they respond to
it stuff I just I feel like a lot of
games that apart stuff this way can feel
really unfair and when everyone's just
suddenly flagged and homes of blaring
and all that know this seems that of
that style really impressed like again
change a weapon yeah
I might see Selena
I think this gameplay was fantastic it's
one honestly like if this were a three
and we were watching this during e3
showcase yeah this would be like up the
game of show it's like don't let the
state of play thing ruin the hype this
is super impressive gameplay
you Nora
that would have taken me a long time to
see I wouldn't have found that for ages
thank you for letting me know where that
is for when I get to this part of the
game I really appreciate that you're
gonna tell us where she went Isaac talks
to us about this I'm getting tired of
this Nora Nora I'm not going down for
her man
I'd seen our animation I'm sure you see
that every time goes long you didn't
take the you did with the tape you need
you can't take the tape dog don't scream
it's the one I'm swearing I'm offended
she does work under me same
I really enjoyed that
they just sold me on the gameplay more
than I had ever been sold before
[Music]
I'm wondering if that was Riley I don't
know see what everyone else thinks I'm
not not entirely sure but damn really
impressed with that gameplay yeah it's
it looks like there are so many options
ways to approach things just get rid of
that huge fan yep
on board sign me up have a good one
everyone's here